Enon says, it just seemed that Queen Creek was pretty obvious right off the bat.
A lot of the areas, yeah, and that's probably true, but you notice the difference.
Let me show you. Well, I can just share my screen and show you this.
Okay, let's look at this.
Population, Queen Creek, Arizona is 59,000 a couple of years ago. Let's look at we say if we type in 2023.
Okay, 78,000. Let's do the same thing for Jacksonville, Florida, almost a million.
Okay, so let me just say this, Enon. The more population, usually the more business owners,
usually the more variables. And so I would go as far as to say that the lower population cities,
it's going to be more cut and dry. And that is why I mentioned in the training,
I have done very, very well in going into this as small of city as possible that still has the
search volume. So I start at the 50,000 or the 40,000, and then I look and I'll look at 20 cities
and find the one or two that actually have enough search volume. And then I'll start doing due
diligence instead of like my rule of thumb is if I look at a map, and I look at the map, and I look
at the map, and I look at the map, and I look at the map, and I look at the map, and I look at the
map, and I can see the city, everyone else can see the city, and that's probably on their list to
go and look at first. That makes sense? So I understand the frustration is like, well, obviously,
Nick, Queen Creek was cut and dry. Go look at cities between 50,000 and 80,000 across the US
in pavers, and you're going to see stuff that's a lot more cut and dry. The bigger the city,
the more competition, the more variables. And that's just the reality. Now, also in that same
breadth, usually the bigger the win. If you can get ranked, like I would love to see somebody that
has SEMrush, go and type in that Jacksonville paversfl.com. Go look at the amount of traffic.
I bet they're getting a hell of traffic because it's such a big city. But I'm telling you, Edward,
I would not be going into that city. It's too competitive. It's too big. The CPC is too high.
Okay. Hopefully, that answered your question, Ema.